these are the famous dots so you just
have to say how many dots there are -
that's very good and you're quite quick
now next one six okay you're accurate
there but you're a bit slower well I've
been particularly interested in the last
few years in dyscalculia which is a
congenital condition that affects
somewhere between three and six percent
of the population and what it means is
that they're very very bad at learning
arithmetic at least learning it in the
normal way and this is a seems to be a
lifelong condition we've met a lot of
adults who have this condition adults
are very successful in other branches of
other walks of life walks of life that
don't depend very much on being good
with numbers I mean they can be
filmmakers TV producers they can even be
science journalists so not going to be
terribly good at doing the maths for
physics
well it's it's like dyslexia in the
following way that it's something that
you're meant to learn at school and that
unless you have special help you're not
going to learn it at school it's not
exactly the same as dyslexia though it's
often called dyslexia for numbers
because dyslexia is a problem in reading
but in fact it's really a problem of
language dyslexia so you have a
particular problem with analyzing the
sounds of language and that's really
what prevents you from linking letters
with sounds particularly for an auto
Rafi like English orthography where the
relationship between letters and sounds
is not particularly consistent that's
the difference between someone who has
dyscalculia and someone who's just a bit
rubbish at math the difference between
discount QD and just being rubbish at
maths is that lots of reasons for being
rubbish at maths my own excuse is that I
didn't have a very good maths teacher at
school and I didn't like him and get on
with him I've had to try and desperately
to make up for that sense for example
you might miss a lot of lessons and
since since math is a kind of cumulative
subject unlike history then you know if
you miss a lot of stuff it's very hard
to catch up dis calcula it can occur in
people with high intelligence good
memories who go to school every day have
really supportive backgrounds and yet
they're unable to do what everybody else
in their class can do they do simple
arithmetic so there is a difference you
can often spot a dis calculate though
these aren't formal tests and in lots of
different ways for example they have
great difficulty in remembering
telephone numbers I have difficulty
remembering any numbers so they often
are going to use the same pin for when
they shouldn't for lots of different
activities they're very bad at shopping
so actually one of the first
developmental disc alcoholics that we we
came across was in prison and he was in
prison for shoplifting why did he
shoplift well because he was too
embarrassed to go to the counter because
he didn't know how much money to give
who's getting the right change so
shopping is an area which is really
difficult for discs our queue leaks they
also have trouble with time it's not
that they can't estimate intervals it's
just that they're not very good at the
numerical side of it working out for
example what time they have to leave
home in order to get some to somewhere
at a particular time we know that
there's a particular part of the brain
that seems to be involved in very simple
number tasks so for example here in the
parietal lobes of the brain this is the
back of the brain this is the left
parietal that's the right parietal
we know that these areas are critical
for just enumerated number of objects in
a set one of the things that we know is
that we now know it's very recent
discovery is that dis calculus have
abnormalities particularly in both of
these areas and maybe particularly in
the left in in in older dyscalculia 'xs
so they they have abnormal structure and
also the brain activates in different
way when they're doing number tasks now
why should they have abnormal structure
or abnormal activations well there are a
number of possible reasons we don't know
all of them one of them is these
abnormalities seem to be in some cases
inherited one of the things we do know
is that there are particular genetic
abnormalities that seem to affect
numbers more than other cognitive
abilities so abnormalities in the in the
X chromosome seem to seem to have an
effect on parietal lobe development and
also on American abilities so
individuals with a number of different X
chromosome conditions like Turner's
syndrome where you have only one
complete X chromosome or fragile X
syndrome they seem to have a big effect
on your ability to do even very simple
number tasks
how do you diagnose this how do you make
the decision yet that person's got the
problem well it in the in the study that
we've just published we used two
criteria and one is you've got to be bad
at arithmetic and it's important to note
there's got to be it's time to rithmetic
that's critical here because there's a
difference between somebody who answers
the question what's five plus three with
eight and the individual who goes five
plus three is eight so time is a very
good diagnostic here and we also looked
at the ability to just enumerate sets so
how many dots are there on the screen
now how good you are at this is a very
even in kindergarten in one of our
studies is a very good predictor at how
much difficulty you're going to have in
learning arithmetic what is it about
counting dots counting dots aims2 is it
just because it's a good easy dependable
test or is there something more talk
than I'm missing it's a very dependable
test so if you're batted in at five your
battery's at six you're bad at seven
you're ballad well up until 11 that's in
our longitudinal study that's as far as
we've gone so far so it's a very stable
indicator so that's one reason the other
reason is because it links to the kinds
of things that might be inherited the
kinds of things that that other species
are able to do what do we do with
someone who's got it then other drugs
they can take is there something that
can be done there was another basket
case yeah no they're not basket cases
but like dyslexia what you need is
special kinds of intervention so if
they're not very good at enumerated on't
have a very good sense of of the number
of objects in the set so if it's a set
of five not very good at enumerated it
means they don't have a very good sense
of what five nurses so what you have to
do is you have to have interventions
that the target that particular weakness
so you can lots of practice as
enumerated sets linking that enumeration
with the symbols that we use for sets
like the word five
and the digit five and in fact you can
you can relate the number of dots to how
long it takes you so unsurprisingly you
might say the more dots there are the
longer it takes you to give the right
answer but there's a very reliable
result which we've known for least 50
years which is that up to about four
dots you're very accurate and you're
pretty fast and thereafter it takes you
about an extra quarter of a second for
each additional dot and this is
sometimes called the sabotaging range
and that's called the counting or
estimating range and there's a point at
which you go from one range to the other
range and that suggests there are
actually two processes at work here and
we know actually from some recent
neuroimaging studies that we've done
that there are in fact there's a
separate part of the brain that does the
sabotaging range from the estimating
range well at how many dots does it
become reasonable for someone to make a
mistake because I feel a lot of pressure
doesn't if you put up 30 or so that
would take me a long time to count right
I mean that this is a very very fair
point if you give people unlimited time
and you tell them they have to be
accurate they'll just count them and
that'd be pretty good at counting them
if you give them limited amount of time
then they can count them up to a point
so this for example this is this is from
children so it's taking them seven
seconds to get to eight dots but if you
gave them less time to do it then of
course they'd have to estimate and it
looks as though for big numbers you use
a somewhat different process then when
you're doing an exact enumeration what
do I do for being numbers we you make an
estimate which is based on extracting
various visual properties from the
stimulus and there's now some brilliant
work done by Marcos Ortiz lab in in
Italy where they've modeled how this
might work but for the numbers up to
about nine or ten but some people might
be a bit more there's a way in which you
kind of
can enumerate even if you're not
actually verbally counting I feel like
when I'm doing it like when you showed
me the six I counted three and then I
kind of made a little split and counted
another three and them together is is
that a normal thing is everyone doing
that or are people some people counting
them one by one or discal qyx will count
one by one this is one of the
interesting things about this gal qxa
they're very bad at doing the estimating
using the estimating strategy you can do
it with three and three we've done some
work on this but you won't do it on
three and four so you won't save as a
group of three there's a group of four
it doesn't give you any advantage for
reasons we don't fully understand having
to visually separable groups of the same
number is an advantage but having to
visually separable groups of different
numbers for reasons I didn't understand
doesn't give you any advantage oh you
know more than me honestly like with
seven I would count three and four maybe
I would do three in two I don't know
well coming to the lab for some tests so
we'll see what you really do it's true
there yes correct